معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام
ما الذي رصدته في وسط القطاع من قصف
اسرائيليه ربما وسط القطاع بات يتعرض الى
القصف الاعنف في قطاع غزه لا سما وان
العمليه البريه حديثه العهد لا سما بعد ان
دخلت القوات الاسرائيليه وتوغلت من مخيم
البريج وبعد ذلك تمدد هذا التوغل الى مخيم
المغازي والان المحور الجديد هو محور
منطقه الزوايده حيث باتت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه متواجده على شارع صلاح الدين
والان تحاول الدخول الى منطقه الزوايده
كما دخلت ايضا على اطراف مخيم النصيرات
وبالتالي القصف المدفعي لا يتوقف عن هذه
المناطق قصف مدفعي عنيف ايضا طائرات مسيره
تطلق النار على المواطنين في شارع صلاح
الدين وفي المناطق الداخليه والشوارع
الداخليه للمخيمات مخيمات وسط القطاع
بالاضافه الى الغارات الاسرائيليه التي
باتت مكثفه وتترك ركز على المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه في اكثر من منطقه واكثر من
محافظه لكن في منطقه وسط القطاع بات القصف
مركزا على هذه المنطقه قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه على مدار الساعات
الماضيه عده منازل في دير البلح وايضا في
مخيم النصيرات وفي مخيم البريج وكذلك في
مخيم المغازي ايضا في مخيم المغازي
استهدفت مدرسه للايواء لكن ربما عرف
وصور المنزل في مخيم في منطقه دير البلح
وفي مخيمات اللجوء الفلسطيني في مخيم
المغازي والبريج والنصيرات لم تستطع
الطواقم الصحفيه الدخول الى هذا المخيم
وتبين طبيعه هذه الاهداف التي قصفتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه حتى ان
سيارات الاسعاف سيارات الدفاع المدني لا
تستطيع الوصول الى هذه المخيمات بفعل
القصف الاسرائيلي المستمر والمتواصل على
هذه المخيمات بالاضافه الى الطائرات
المسيره التي تطلق النار على كل من يحاول
الدخول الى هذه المخيمات كما ان هناك
قناصه اسرائيليون من الجنود الاسرائيليين
متواجدين على اعتلوا بعض المنازل والمباني
المرتفعه على مدخل مخيم المغازي ايضا في
مخيم البريج ويطلقون النار على كل من
يحاول الدخول لاجلاء المصابين وانتشال
الجثامين من هذه المناطق بالتالي هناك قصف
عنيف ومستمر ومتواصل لا سما من المدفعيه
ايضا في المناطق الشرقيه لمخيم البريج
مخيم المغازي ايضا منطقه شرق دير البلح
تتعرض هذه المناطق الى قصف من مدفعيه وقصف
عنيف على مدار الساعه كذلك المناطق
الشماليه لمخيم لمخيم النصيرات تتعرض الى
قصف عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وجل
استهدافات المدفعيه هي منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه قريبه من عمليات التوغل وايضا في
مناطق قلب هذه المخيمات الفلسطينيه هذه
المخيمات الفلسطينيه لا يزال فيها الالاف
من
السكان مصرون على البقاء في هذه في
منازلهم لا سما وان كل مناطق قطاع غزه
باتت مكتظه عن بكره ابيها منطقه النازحون
يتجمعون في منطقتين اساسيتين هما دير
البلح ورفح دير البلح تتعرض الى قصف ما
بين فينه واخرى من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه واغلب هذه المناطق والمنازل
التي يستهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي هي منازل
يتواجد فيها نازحون فلسطينيون وايضا في
رفح كما حدث الليله الماضيه عندما استهدف
الجيش الاسرائيلي على الاقل خمسه منازل في
اكثر من منطقه في رفح في الشابوره وفي يبن
وايضا في منطقه موراج وكلها منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه يتواجد فيها نازحون نحن في رفح
ولا تستطيع ولا يوجد مساحه لقدم واحده
جديده في رفح لكن رغم كل ذلك المنازل
ممتلئه السكان يحاولون مساعده بعضهم البعض
والتضامن مع بعضهم البعض ولكن يلاحقهم
القصف الاسرائيلي في كل هذه المناطق في
خانيونس ايضا استهدف الجيش الاسرائيلي
منزلا وكان هناك عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى
واجل الشهداء وحتى الجرحى هم اطفال من
جراء ان هذه المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه
السكان يتركون المنازل
والاماكن الدافئه لابنائهم وايضا للنساء
وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي في جل عمليات
القصف يكون هناك جرحى من وشهداء من النساء
والاطفال في عمليات القصف كافه في كافه
محافظات قطاع غزه شكرا لك من رفح مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوط